hello rejects how are you guys doing my
name is Greg I am paranoid like his on
with me as the lovely Selena she hasn't
been on this channel and so long it's
been a long long time elf recut as a
thriller as a thriller they made it
great all around the movie elf wait is
it scary I don't know I think it's
supposed to be funny
it's from the channel Cinna fix and
Cinna fix isn't like it's one of my
favorite YouTube channels I'm pretty
excited for this I love L my dad like my
favorite yes my dad was best friend okay
he's also the guy who played carp he
played the old guy in up Y like the
voice yeah the voice my face something
like how you came across off of him yeah
okay
[Music]
yeah yeah I think someone sent you a
christmas-gram
[Music]
I'm here to see a Walter Hobbs
this music refined you you look like you
[Music]
[Music]
probably just reverting to a state of
childlike dependency
[Music]
he needs to be nurtured so felonies are
fun now to introduce you to Emily
Michael comes to terms with reality
[Music]
Oh like it fits so perfectly because his
freaking face is so creepy all the time
as well yeah they took like all those
elements of elf where they took the time
to kind of go well here's why he might
just be just like because we as the
audience no he's not but this trailer
was smart because it didn't show us any
of like the actual like North Pole stuff
it's just looking from the perspective
of everyone not knowing that and it was
so well that's at the point that I was
like you know if they just like shop us
a little different this could have been
a legit like thriller like really messed
up like one crazy Christmas because it
was more than just funny at times it was
like has he ever played like a serial
killer girl yeah you could tell totally
could mean you could totally play it so
yeah I would be so interested in seeing
him play that oh yeah great film I would
love to be a fly on the wall just to
watch his reaction to that yeah you'd
probably do the laughing seriously
well just stop acting and just do
reactions he should be on all right
rejects if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe today get accepted also
subscribe to these [ __ ] Cinna
fixes seriously seriously an awesome
channel it's their movie list that I
love I think they do the coolest kind of
movie list they're more than just like
best movies of them as of like a week
ago they uploaded three brilliant
moments and the visuals of character so
it's like a much more detailed in-depth
look and yeah and I feel like you're
learning something yes forever it's all
right so I think they are a truly
amazing channel because their list
videos I feel like it's film school when
I'm it's more than just an opinion and
also chelina is on Instagram add light
coach
he'll study sense yeah I'm a light coach
for the world I love sharing my
experience on this earth she's snapping
champ like helping people find their
light that's beautiful that's beautiful
so I gotta go to her Instagram and so
snapchats a lot
yeah throughout the day feel her
experiences in life and she's also the
host and coordinator of this event
called color my energy and it's like
monthly bimonthly yeah the third
Wednesday of every month yeah downtown
oh I've performed there a couple times
we lock spoken word that's right yeah we
would love to have you back cuz it was
really fun I like to write poetry
somebody who would know now you know
this guy super deep ice cream